as Athenians levy as minorities we need
a little bit of racism I'm not talking
like plunger and the axe racism black
people can keep that [ __ ] I'm saying Jos
enough racism to remind us who we are
the right insurgents
you know I've never been searched at the
airport you're not [ __ ] embarrassing
man Jenny never get stuck to the airport
I'm so excluded from my virginity
opposition because you know there's like
what - I don't need to get discriminated
against the same way it's like I'm open
to bonding to them right I can connect
over that [ __ ] I left the [ __ ] out of
that conversation every time me and
Brian friends we talked in one that'll
be like dude I got search for 20 minutes
on my last airplane flight and I said oh
I got search for 35 minutes
hold my last airplanes like you'll see
like a connection in their eyes right
make it just happen they're gonna try to
draw me in they'll be like what about
you then he told me Mexicans don't blow
up lands Thanks
they told me they manage me to fix the
plane
it's good to be himself man I'm glad you
are laughing at that [ __ ] I'll born and
raised don't want to raise in Dallas
Texas anybody who does yeah good to be
in the South Vegas we have fun with that
racing right like the no other ones
don't get there the sound isn't more
races we just we cook around yeah like
my whole roommates in college for black
dudes my best friends on that campus but
we would have fun with that [ __ ] like
they would pull up to a gas station with
me and they'd say some [ __ ] language or
just like that
can't clock back and forth is far in
this one let me tell you this want you
to put on that little towel till your
cousins in Iraq to give up that oil this
is a boy everybody all right okay well
why are you so afraid of jail when we
both know that's the only place you'll
ever find your real father
fun with it New York is pretty [ __ ]
tighten it anytime anybody brings up
color at all it is a person's whole soul
hangs up I live in New York now you say
don't even like a sign coming like you
know not fixing [ __ ] is good call
somebody be like hey man I like the
jacket if you're part of the other night
it's a young so it's a north color it's
very fine it's some African American
okay our multi african-american because
I got like a light-skinned cream color
it's in a fishing spot the South gonna
handle that conversation [ __ ] that
medium-high payment other the jacket
over there it's a black dogfish all
right it's a Wesley Snipes black